depuis deux ans les proches de steve can
i saw accusent les forces de l'ordre par
les méthodes et moyens employés lors de
leurs interventions d'être responsable
de sa chute dans la loi avec les
lacrymogènes et s'étaient renvoyé pas
forcément on allait du coup tout le
monde courait à droite à quand j'étais
vraiment le la panique générale
et c'est là qu'il ya les gens commencent
à semer dans la loire jeudi dernier le
parquet de rennes semble leur avoir
donné en partie raison
le procureur de la république a déclaré
que l'analyse des relevés du téléphone
de steve a permis je cite de situer le
moment de la chute dans la loire à 4
heures et 33 minutes soit le temps de
l'intervention de la police nationale
problème cette affirmation vient
totalement contredire le rapport de
l'igpn qui lui mettait hors de cause les
agents de police en se fondant sur
l'horaire du dernier relais déclenchée
par le téléphone
une heure plus tôt il ne peut être
établi de lien entre l'intervention des
forces de police et la disparition de
monsieur steve mailhac à nice au un
rapport de l'igpn très vite critiqué
notamment pour sa partialité
aucun mouvement de foule n'avait été
constatée et aucun témoin non policier
entendu n'avait observé de personnes en
panique ou en train de courir il n'y a
pas à remettre en cause l'intervention
collective des forces de l'ordre
interrogée par la presse plusieurs
personnes présentes ce jour-là remet
d'ailleurs témoigner d'une réalité toute
différente une deuxième salve a été
tirée cette fois le nuage de lacrymo
était très impressionnant et on a perdu
en visibilité
comme lorsque cela pèse sur les grosses
manifs dans le centre ville de nantes
on entendait des explosions des gens
criaient et couraient désorientés
j'avais tellement les yeux qui pleurait
que je n'ai retrouvé mes équipiers cas
l'ambulance je ne sais pas quelle est la
définition du mouvement de foule pour
l'igpn
mais j'aimerais comprendre si c'est un
grand nombre de personnes qui fuient
rapidement un nuage de gaz lacrymogène
alors oui il y en a eu un
et puis ici les policiers ont fait usage
de gaz lacrymogènes les crs arrivés sur
les lieux une vingtaine de minutes après
le début de l'intervention eux ont
préféré s'abstenir
techniquement eu égard à la
configuration des lieux et à l'absence
de garde-corps sur le quai je me refuse
à l'utilisation de tous moyens
lacrymogène pour éviter les mouvements
de panique et les possibles chute dans
le fleuve voisin à faible concentration
dans l'atmosphère le gaz lacrymogènes
irrite fortement les yeux et provoque
déjà une
non négligeable et à plus forte densité
il brouille totalement la vue peut
provoquer des quintes de toux lorsqu'il
est inhalé voir des vomissements et
occasionné des vertiges et une perte de
connaissance alors oui lorsqu'une
grenade éclate au milieu d'un
rassemblement de plusieurs centaines de
personnes
le mouvement de foule qui en résulte
peut être impressionnant comme sur ces
images d'un rassemblement contre les
violences policières
il y a un an en quelques secondes des
centaines de personnes recul de
plusieurs dizaines de mètres pour tenter
d'échapper aux effets des gaz tirées par
les forces de l'ordre
imaginez désormais la même scène aux
abords d'un fleuve et on comprend bien
pourquoi la décision d'employer des gaz
lacrymogènes sur le quai wilson il y a
deux ans et très critiquée des vidéos de
cette nuit semble à tout le moins à
tester de l' usage par les policiers de
grenades lacrymogènes à proximité
directe du fleuve le contexte
géographique est générale en présence
d'individus potentiellement sous l'effet
d'alcool ou de stupéfiants ne peut
échapper à l'expérience de policiers
aguerris et à leur hiérarchie
d'ailleurs comme le fait remarquer
mediapart en 2017 au même endroit au
cours de la même fête de la musique
les policiers étaient intervenus sans
cette fois tiré la moindre grenade et il
était pourtant déjà comme il y a deux
ans la cible de projectiles lancés par
les fêtards mais la doctrine de maintien
de l'ordre semble s'être encore durcies
depuis comme en a attesté à de
nombreuses reprises la crise des gilet
jaune ou encore les heures de ce week
end où un homme a eu la main arrachée
par l'explosion d'une grenade à redon
près de nantes justement une doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre plusieurs fois
condamné par la communauté
internationale notamment le haut
commissariat des droits de l'homme de
l'onu où le parlement européen d appel
auquel paris est jusqu'ici resté sourd
malheureusement pour steve can i saw